so we need this
equipment from gas masks to blankets and
everything in between
ukrainian volunteers have created their
own supply chains and delivery networks
to support the war efforts it's
necessary for me for
my family for my country because i'm
afraid for
our
life global news was invited into one of
the group's warehouses in the capitol
and witnessed a bustling operation
we distribute to refugees who are in
kiev who come from all over ukraine from
those cities where hostilities are
taking place in peace time supplies for
vulnerable people were collected here
now in a time of war
everyone is vulnerable
supplies are most needed in areas cut
off or under attack volunteers work with
partners to select priority items find
the safest times to travel and which
routes to take
deliveries have also been timed with
rescues the volunteer network has been
repeatedly contacted by people
looking for safe passage
we got a lot of
phone calls from our friends
from
people that we
don't know
and some letters messengers
in facebook please help us over the past
two months they have driven supplies
into bucha erpin kramatorsk and driven
out women and children
often under dangerous conditions sure
scared because
it's dangerous we understand it but
we don't have any
way
we need to support each other
a few hours away in chernihev protective
vests make their way to those who need
them the liberated city is quiet now but
in march it was completely encircled and
there were fears it would fall
the vote itself is not over when it is
quiet in the city something inside me
motivates me to do more and to continue
to do what i am doing
a chain of like-minded people united by
a sense of duty convinced victory and
peace will come
crystal commencing global news
keefe